by 237 bound for Geneva is circling the
city after an engine
you're out there now Kara I'm her the
woman who saved the plane Hey oh cool
they made a TV show about me I'm kidding
I know where Cape in public I'm on a
lorry and we're here to talk about how
DC just spidered shots at Marvel getting
hot in here take off all your cape am i
right
this is hash technics
Oh interesting right when Marvel is in
trouble with all of the black widow
controversy DC decides to release a
trailer for its new female superhero TV
show Supergirl
huh interesting timing what Supergirl DC
has decided to go bold and spotlight a
female superhero what a difficult
concept to grasp some people feel like
they're hitting the girls rule angle
kind of hard for instance this title
personally I'm okay with getting hit
over the head with feminism as long as
we're getting hit on the head at all
Studios are recognizing that we want to
see female fronted stuff Wonder Woman's
getting a movie or is now a woman
they're recasting President Clinton as a
woman I think the trailer looks pretty
good it does have kind of a Devil Wears
Prada vibe to it
Calista Flockhart playing the Meryl
Streep character but with less eyebrows
my initial thought was why does car have
to be a geeky insecure assistant when
her cousin's Superman got to be a
reporter but some of the themes of the
show are about achieving your potential
so I think it plays in well let's my
full potential watching all of Netflix I
want to get to the end of Netflix also I
don't understand why Superman can't
deliver his own blanket if he can fly
faster than the speed of sound
that's the blanket he was wrapped in
when he was a baby but hey Superman gave
your pal Jimmy Olsen something to do
James O is it James now they try to
explain why Superman doesn't come in the
trailer my cousin wanted me to do this
why did he just tell me because you
wanted to introduce yourself but we all
know it's because every Cavalcanti out
would be too much money I'm really
excited to see where Supergirl goes if
you are too you should subscribe for
more videos like this cuz it's like why
not get like below if you want more this
elbows ah it like blood where you want
more this and leave a comment below
letting us know what you think about
Supergirl is gonna be great or is it can
suck or there are varying opinions in
between those two doesn't you were
together I'm on a lorry and I'm the girl
from that video
wait you saved that plane I know the one
where the girl peels her face off
yeah oh my god
and